[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
wenn ich bin gerade nach frankfurt am
main grad und ich bin gerade in
frankfurt am main dass ein fahrrad kam -
sind wir da hinten am fahrrad steht aber
egal ich bin heute hier als besucher auf
der ambiente messe und zwar ist es
internationale messe und hier sind
wirklich hersteller aus der ganzen welt
hier gibt es ganz viele tolle produkte
im bereich haushaltswaren aber auch im
bereich deko wohnen küche und so weiter
und wir sind heute hier um natürlich zu
schauen was gibt es denn an innovationen
letztes jahr weiter auch schon da ich
möchte natürlich auch nach herstellern
schauen sie vielleicht auch produkte für
mich herstellen können und natürlich
auch nach neuheiten für meinen online
shop und bei das letzte messe video von
der esm also von der süßwarenmesse so
gut ankam
gibt's natürlich auch hier in diesem
video ein gewinnspiel und dieses mal
geht es nicht nur süßigkeiten pakete
sondern ich versuche natürlich auch bei
unseren partner die wir kennen bei
kitchenaid zum beispiel was größeres
rauszuholen küchenmaschine vielleicht
und wenn die mixer geben da muss es
einfach dem radsport soll
ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig kommt
mit dem bus habe ich jetzt verpasst also
renne ich jetzt einfach in die erste
halle und ihr dafür schauen was es neues
gibt
[Musik]
mal
aber ich muss am meisten arbeiten daher
ein ende gefunden hat gesagt dass
gesunde sehr gesund ja halber sei
genauso gut schon heiß frauen man auf
der messe die stimme der und rote beete
ist auch sehr gut für uns noch mal rote
bete für alles für alles live besonders
blut und haben wir sonst noch so im
anderen keinen spaß da ist gut für die
seele
ich habe jetzt ein gutes herz und für
die seele was ist jetzt schon mal sagen
wollte frohe weihnachten ihr wisst ja
nach weihnachten ist vor weihnachten die
weihnachtszeit beginnt schon bald neue
okay wir haben noch ein bisschen bis
dahin aber natürlich muss hier jeder
schon schauen wo er bleibt das ganze
jahr und deswegen gibt es hier schon
weihnachten im februar kann man sich
schon mal um weihnachtsdeko
[Applaus]
ich glaube dass sie auch cdu rat wird
seine richtung witze ich glaube dir
nämlich für den monat märz
ich glaube der trend geht zur vor doch
weihnachten wird dieses jahr wird das
wird meine ecke weihnachten wird doch
pink und rosa guckt kommen wir von den
schönen schriften zu den schönen räumen
davor da muss ich mal was zeigen so
genial wie ablassen kommt man mit
[Musik]
hallo ich freue mich es gibt dir das mal
dass zugleich mit dabei sein
ja hier bin ich gerade bei den via
platten und zwar kommen sie später auch
bei uns zu hause der food 11 10
und es sind wirklich geniale platten
also ein ganz ganz toller fußbodenbelag
mit dem wir einfach eine ganz tolle
atmosphäre zu hause schaffen kann
bei uns in der küche bei uns im
badezimmer und die sind wirklich
wunderschön erklärt wirklich
wunderschöne hat ganz ganz tolle design
ja und wir bekommen bald besuchen ich
war schon mal gesehen und ich war
wirklich total beeindruckt auch wenn ich
das hier hinten sehen richtig schön aber
da freue ich mich schon seit auch ich
kann mir kann ja vielleicht mal den
fußboden zeigt den verein bekommt ja die
navigation nicht liegen aber man
auf den bildern habe ich gerade in der
werbedruck darauf so schnell
die sprüche kommen und hier vorne haben
wir auch einen raum
ja das bei euch zu hause gelten
guck mal das ist nicht einfach aus dass
uns natürlich meine auch wenn man sie in
die hand nehmen nicht so etwas
besonderes ja das ist halt einfach eine
materialität also die haben eine dicke
die sind auch der schichtdicke von drei
millimetern durchgefärbt also es ist
nicht einfach so bunt bedrucktes zu
lehren sondern das sind wirklich
geschieht und handarbeit ja da oben
sieht man in der werkstatt wo ich
gelernt habe
die 20 jahre her
und hier sieht es auch die schablone mit
der platten gemacht werden und sie
müssen dann halt trocknen in diesen
regalen und dann gibt es bei unseren
internetseiten
wo man mit dem verleger programm die
selber so virtuell verleger und was man
sagen soll und wer ist das hier
wir sind ja ein familienunternehmen
bei manchen ja endlich machen die kinder
auch immer gerne mit
gerade das ist eins meiner
lieblingsbilder echt schön einfach
mitten aus dem leben heraus
ja und ich danke dir bekommen sich ganz
bald besuchen als ihr könnt ganz bald
auch mehr sehen von almut und content
wieder platten und ich freue mich
richtig drauf also wirklich ganz ganz
arg acht danke euren besuch und aus
projekt
das nehme ich mit und das lasse ich dir
danke
[Musik]
es gibt einfach stände auf der messe
zähne muss ich wirklich jedes jahr weil
einfach mein herz dafür schlägt hier
seht ihr den schönen regenbogen das ist
der kitchenette regenbogen und ich
glaube diese tollen bunten farben gibt
auch nur hier
[Musik]
da aber die himbeereis meine allererste
maschine und immer noch mein favorit
aber ich glaube hier um die ecke gibt es
sogar nur fahren
die farben 2018 und dies wird ihr hier
der trend geht ja wirklich zum arzt
haben wir von matrosen macht blau oben
haben wir noch choral das ist auch so
eine trendfarbe und wirklich immer
wieder schön und es ist ja echt so also
ich könnte jeden tag eine andere
maschine mit rein stellen weil ich hier
alle farben schön finden aber muss auch
für eine entscheiden und hier auf dem
stand bin ich wirklich jedes ja ich
arbeite ja auch schon seit über vier
jahren mit kitchenette zusammen und das
war wirklich eine ganz tolle
freundschaft entstanden nicht nur zur
maschine sondern auch zu den menschen
die hinter der maschine stehen und ich
zeige euch jetzt mal welche das sagen
hat ist nämlich eine frau
[Musik]
nicole frauenpower hier freut mich damit
gerade schon den neuen farben entdeckt
die sind nicht so schön
erzähl mal was gibt's neues paket fort
ja wir haben wie immer die neuen
maschinen den supercup trends und höher
sind die koralle wie hast ich glaube
schon sehen ich lieb' korane ja das ist
so schön dann den marken pastell tool er
ein traum der in diesem buch oder
pastell bleibe auf jeden fall vielen
tücken also kann es ja toll und hier
gehts ja auch die ganzen drehung ist
auch also wie wir das uns auf morgen im
aktuellen session aber ihr habt ihr
nicht nur neue farben sondern auch neue
neues zubehör erst haben wir in einem
geheimen raum möchte ich jetzt gerne ein
wenn du möchte also eben the secret room
danach wirklich nicht jeder rein aber
weil ihr seid der firma mit sommer
gucken und wir kommen gleich zum
probieren
der geheimrat hier sind wir in uns mal
ein paar inspirationen ja im moment
ziemlich noch unter verschluss halten
name ist hier natürlich was für
möglichkeiten haben wir eigentlich alle
auch um mal maschine diese persönlicher
nachdem meinen wünschen zu kreieren ist
wirklich richtig tor lian edelstahl
schüsseln
unterschiedlichen designs oder
kartierungen
dann muss aber behrami schüsseln die
auch wie leicht daher als die alten
olja das merke ich schon die allgemeine
wirklich furchtbar schwer so da brauchen
wir jetzt nicht solche auch so ganz gut
hin
sehr schön und natürlich neben den
designten keramik schüsseln und das weg
zur jahreszeit passen oder in die küche
möchte steht natürlich hier einen haken
weil die neuen maschinen gefahren hat
hier gezeigt aber das neue auch daran
ist dass wir dann edelstahl perfekt das
heißt sie können euch immer schwierig
das könnte mit der hand zu reinigen aber
meist so im ablauf und dann denkt man
komme alles sind die spülmaschine rein
und insofern sehr schön ist das perfekt
und war da haben wir natürlich dann den
übergang edelstahl edelstahl
wir kommen mit einem edelstahl kann der
auch endlich in die spülmaschine genau
und mit dem fleischwolf kam er nicht nur
fleisch wolfen sondern auch die gemüse
man kann auch gemüse pettys und so
weiter machen also fleisch von peter
totalen vielseitigen ist geplatzt aber
alle ich habe mit meinem mann neulich in
kanälen bürger damit fehlen dadurch gilt
der aktor universales verkleinern auch
nicht mehr cool und da hinten und hat
dieser decke unter das schwarzen da
gibt's noch eine neuheit aber die dürfen
wir jetzt nicht zeigen okay das ist echt
eine richtige weltneuheit also sowas hab
noch nicht gegeben
und da dürfte echt gespannt sein und wir
gehen jetzt raus weg von der rekorde die
eigentlich das gesicht von kitchenaid
ist in deutschland kann man schon sagen
jetzt gehen wir nach draußen zum steffen
mister nice guys sagt murat immer auch
ein schwabe und murat und steffen die
lieben sich heiß und innig und ich
dachte steffen hat was ganz ganz tolles
für euch
[Musik]
als steffen normalerweise sind ja
schwaben ziemlich geizig also ich weiß
davon murad von dem bekomme ich nichts
umsonst also ganz ganz schwierig wir
sind sehr sehr sparsam geschworen wir
partner sagen aber das ist was anderes
das nicht das problem was wir heute
lösen wollen
was hast du für uns für unsere zuschauer
dicht hält für dich trifft einmal eine
maschine verloren nein doch deine
lieblings maschine musste schon
ausgesucht neben der 14
habt ihr das gehört wir dürfen eine
kitchenette verlosen das heißt wir die
kitchenaid haben möchtet in himbeereis
von stefan höchst persönlich übergeben
dann kommentiert einfach mit herrschte
kitchenaid etwas ganz besonderes ist
danke dir danke also kommentiert ganz
fleißig und dann bekommt ihr die
kitchenaid in himbeereis hammer danke
[Musik]
aber jetzt bin ich hier bei gvo geht so
kennt ihr wahrscheinlich schon auf
meinen videos ich habe nämlich ganz
viele praktische helfer schon bei mir in
der küche und die andere zeigt mir
gerade das neueste produkt das ist der
fleck hat und es sieht so einfach aus
nach ich das auch mal ausprobieren
ich komme zu dir
als wir haben ja oft einfach nur die
kartoffel reinlegen hat sich die
kartoffel rhein liegt dann sitzt du den
schon habe ich meine kartoffeln und
zwiebeln noch mal ausprobieren das ist
dann halt echt gut aus
das geht das so einfach das kann sogar
der murat hitir geht auch hier eine
gurke geht auch du kannst du einfach
oben rein steckt und wir daraus ziehen
weil das ist die ganze burg immer gerne
selber genau die ganze reinstecken
aber ich habe blumen und die sie
verschenken foto afp ich habe für diesen
orten strauß gemacht was wir über ganz
liefern ist ja einfach rein tippen und
sofort acht stück ja auf jeden fall
das wurde dann geschnitten ich habe sie
mit dem fleck weg abgeschnitten
irgendwo dort ist nämlich
geschäftsführer und gv sein sohn haben
wir auch gerade rené und was teure
produkte aus also ich weiß ist
eigentlich schon aber vielleicht kannst
dass er meinen zuschauern sagen also bei
unseren produkten ist die funktionalität
das oberste gebot
das design muss immer stimmig sein es
muss emotional rüberkommen und zwar spaß
machen mit diesen produkten zu arbeiten
das macht jeden fall und qualität ist
natürlich auch ganz qualität da sehen
wir schon gar nicht mal drüber qualität
ist oberster standard
das gehört aber dazu also in meiner
küche durften eure geräte schon ein 10
vielleicht habt ihr auch was für meine
zuschauer wir haben ganz tolles gerade
das ist der neue flexi hat er das ist
das neue modell
damit kann ich also spalten damit kann
ich kartoffelspalten das wird entweder
getötet oder geachtet damit mache ich
meine kirschtomaten damit mache ich
meine kartoffeln patch ist also ist
wirklich vielseitig einzusetzen des
morgens vom frühstück bis zum nachmittag
salat oder als abend halt eben beim
steak die wunderschöne welches dazu
schön knackig zu wenn ihr gerne auch mit
dem flexi kat von d du jemandem einen
blumenstrauß bzw kurzen staus machen
möchtet dann kommentiert einfach mit dem
hashtag depot und da gehört auch euch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die hat mir gar nicht also sie ist fast
also wenn ich mich mit kunden behalten
muss eine gute hab ich das ding an und
das ist aus der ferne ist das geräusch
das ist schon alles schneider kenne ich
auch von meiner mama denn auch bei sich
in der küche steht und viele denken ja
dass man damit nur brot schneiden kann
aber an alles schneider da ist wirklich
super viel zeit ist ich kann damit zum
beispiel obst und gemüse schneiden ich
kann auch horst schneiden natürlich auch
brot schneiden und es sieht so einfach
aus und auch die handhabung ist wirklich
sehr sicher also an bord hat keine angst
davor haben
ich zeige euch doch mal eben da habe ich
dich ganz auflösen
trainier 1
die gewinnstärke einstein monate
anschaut noch 4
und schon habt ihr perfekte dünn
geschnittenen scheiben sie können zu
essen ihr könnt noch anbraten
oder was sie auch machen können ist klar
immer so schön trocknen
da gibt's nämlich da hinten schon eine
neue maschine die zeigen sich mal eben
und zwar geht es denn der automaten da
kann man wirklich dieses snacks ganz
einfach selber zubereiten denn der
automaten gibt selbst nicht genau den
haben wir jetzt hier ganz neu
vorgestellt also den wird dann ab april
im handel verfügbar sein holt er muss
hier auf jeden fall ausprobieren denn
alles schneider den nehme ich schon mit
nach hause dann gibts auch demnächst bei
uns im shop da ist wirklich super genial
und ihr habt doch bestimmt auch was tun
wenn der zuschauer oder auf jeden fall
also da können wir vielleicht einmal
kurz darüber gehen ja das wäre dann die
saale schnell da der motor schön komplex
genug platz in jeder küche
das ist ja echt genial und das hat er
gar nicht so weit weg von uns genau wie
sitz in arnsberg also kommt uns auch
gerne was mache ich auf jeden fall ein
regionales unternehmen in deutschland
und da gehe ich auf jeden fall mal
vorbei und fand ihr denn alles schneider
gewinnen wollt dann schreibt einfach
griff in die kommentare und dann kommt
da zu euch nach hause
[Musik]
endlich ein bekanntes gesicht - carsten
ich habe ja da war ja gestern schon bald
kleine der mubarak genau sagte auch
schon dass du die besucher kommen jahr
habe ich mich sehr geärgert freue ich
mich drüber und ja schon erzählt vom
leckeren essen hier hat er ja tief was
ich mache eigentlich er hat lux
messerscharf also ich arbeite hier viele
messer firma japaner die heißen und die
stellen so da machst besser hier das
sind dienen wo du siehst die haben die
schattierung trainer ist das schöne
muster genau das lässt sich jetzt lima
wo das heißt weil ich der spiegel im
wasser das heißt wenn du oben schießt
das wasser spiegelt sich genau so dass
wieder zwei stahl sowie werden
geschmiedet
oder aber es tut extrem hohen härtegrad
messer wird gemessen in roggwil celsius
temperaturen rock für das härten okay
und wir liegen hier war ein 60 das wird
auch bei 64 das heißt dass essent wir
sind fast am ende des shared files
karten gibt es nur perfekt also profi
messe für zuhause genau er würde das für
zu hause da ich ja wusste dass du kommst
ich wollte ihn für oh ja ich habe einen
besser da nein viel druck für die große
verlosung möchtest du ich habe so
schlechter messer zu hause und ich würde
am liebsten selber behalten aber das
messer bekommt dann wird das verloren ja
ich bin ich bin jetzt so die farmer aus
zu sehen
das ist schon klasse extrem cool aus was
passieren wird am anfang wenn man so ein
neues besser hat das extrem scharf ist
die meisten leute schneiden kann
anfangen man sollte dafür ein riesen
schreck kam er holt immer daran denken
sogar dass gewinnen sollte bei euch ja
die spülmaschine minimal über der hand
muss aber machen wenn ich eine stunde
haben wir das bestimmt zehn jahre dabei
wieder melden das macht doch gewaltig
dann soll es am besten in der junge frau
gewinnen und dann meldet sich in zehn
jahren ohnehin sehr sehr großzügiges
geschenk und wenn ihr dieses messer
gewinnen wollt dann kommentiert mit dem
hashtag unten kein danke
und jetzt ausprobieren dauert zehn
sekunden
super
[Musik]
vermehrten innovation und zwar aus
frankreich ich hab hier keramikgeschirr
und zwar ist es für den herd aber auch
für den backofen oder für die mikrowelle
und der vorteil von keramikgeschirr im
gegensatz so gusseisen ist dass man da
einfach verschiedene formen geben kann
das heißt nicht kann mit zum beispiel
ein ganz tolles design ausdenken und das
geschirr ist auch induktions geeignet
ich hab mir diese kleinen punkte und so
kann ich eben mein gericht auf dem herd
gaben dann den backofen schieben und
hier gibt es zum beispiel die deckel
dazu dh ich kann das ganze dann
verschließen vakuum ihren also die luft
entziehen und später zum beispiel auch
wieder in der mikrowelle warm machen
oder auch einfrieren
also wirklich ganz ganz viele vorteile
und ich bin mal gespannt darauf wird auf
jeden fall mal ausprobieren und euch
dann sagen wie es funktioniert
[Musik]
toll gemacht
ich hoffe es gibt noch bleiben auf
leckeres zum essen ich setze mich schon
mal kommt bestimmt vielleicht
ja hier bin ich jetzt gerade bei trails
man immer ein wieder auch so ich mag
immer ganz gerne und koche ganz gerne
man steht stundenlang in der küche und
dann finde ich immer ganz schade wenn
man das essen ganz leblos auf
irgendwelche teller anrichten was ich
ganz schön führende ist natürlich tisch
kultur das heißt so richtig schön
gedeckter tisch wer freut sich dann
nicht aufs essen und vor allem sind man
da auch ein bisschen länger finde ich
wenn man vorher sich viel mühe gegeben
hat und da ist natürlich das passende
geschenk sehr wichtig seltmann ist eine
firma ausweiten das heißt der deutschen
firma und das porzellan wird auch zu 100
prozent ist deutschland hergestellt vor
drei jahren da war ich gerade schwanger
habe ich die fabrik schon besucht und
habe mir angeschaut wie man
porzellanteller herstellt und habe auch
gelernt was kriterien prokurist
porzellan sind wie zum beispiel der
einfachen fingertipp hier einmal darüber
reiben und mit seltsam zusammen ich
werde jetzt gleich zum michael dann nach
hinten gehen werden wir auch zusammen
und wahrscheinlich eine eigene
kollektion machen also richtig besonders
freue ich mich ganz besonders und ich
finde da noch den morast das schwert
hier auch ingo herum und ich schaue mir
an was hier für neuheiten haben
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt im luxusbereich seltmann
und zwar bei täter ich habe zb sowas
hier stehen
und das ist wirklich was super exklusive
natürlich auch auf der hochpreisiges und
am besten fast gerade herrscht also
finger weg
wenn das kaputtgeht ihr schon ich hier
schon koreaner rumgelaufen hat den löwen
runtergeschmissen 5000 da war nicht
versichert
es kommen ja das kann man erst dass kein
porzellan aus
[Musik]
ich habe zb den richtig schönen teller
es sieht aus wie leder auf meinem teller
ist eine ganz spezielle pflege technik
und das ganze natürlich von bester
qualität und sehr robust und ist einfach
was fein ist was schönes für jeden tag
oder auch für besondere anlässe
[Musik]
erst bei vielen dank für deinen besuch
auf unserem messestand und sehr gefreut
und du bist ja auch bereits eine
nutzerin unsere produkte und einem
täglichen leben auf jeden fall und das
möchten heute auch zum anlassen wie man
um für deine community und deine fans
stellen wir hier einmal zur verlosung
unsere kollektion limit weil man nach
und auftaucht wenn man zur verfügung
ich hoffe dass sich die gewinner genauso
damit beschäftigen und zufrieden sind
wie du selbst ja ich denke also dass
sind die auflaufformen die ich zu hause
bin
aber wenn er nicht noch auflaufformen
sondern hatte immer einen praktischen
decken mit dabei den ich auch einzeln
als servierplatten um servierteller
benutzen kann
die ganzen formen sind offen fest zum
packen zum überbacken und auch zum
servieren auf dem tisch wirklich super
und falls ihr dieses set gewinnen möchte
schreibt einfach hashtags eltmann unten
rein und dann gewiss
[Musik]
hier bin ich jetzt bei der aktion
plagiarius also innovation versus
imitation hier werden nachgemachte
produkte aufgedeckt und es ist wirklich
auf den ersten blick furchtbar schwierig
zu erkennen ob original oder ein
nachgemachtes produkt ist und die werden
dann hier einfach ausgestellt ich zeige
euch jetzt mal so ein paar vereinzelte
[Musik]
jan warum sind plagiate und fälschungen
und so schädlich sie vernichten zum
einen arbeits- und ausbildungsplätze in
deutschland was die entstehen natürlich
auch unter ausbeutung von kinderarbeit
in entwicklungsländern und zu schädigen
massiv deutsche innovative unternehmen
und natürlich hat man auch oft das
problem dass keine qualität oder
funktionalität haben und natürlich auch
die gesundheit oder das leben dafür frau
aufs spiel setzen und natürlich sind
lackierte einfach nur plump und feines
als auch hier der unterschied kaum
erkennbar links der original kopie in
deutschland hergestellt und rechts der
qi gong in china hergestellt und gerade
bei kinderspielzeug muss man echt gut
aufpassen wegen den schädlichen
weichmachern oder auch schädlichen
anderen inhaltsstoffen
[Musik]
und hier kann man auch kaum einen
unterschied erkennen von links zurecht
und der einzige unterschied denn es
macht es eine bekommt man im internet zu
kaufen und das andere in der parfümerie
oder fachhändler
also ich würde den unterschied
wahrscheinlich nicht erkennen der
einzige unterschied besteht darin das
original bekommt man in der parfümerie
oder beim fachhändler und die fälschung
einfach im internet
[Musik]
hierbei weskow ist es auch richtig schön
bunt weskow ist eine firma 150 jahre alt
auf dem sauerland und gerade habe ich
mit der marketingabteilung gesprochen
und ihr bekommt auch hier ein richtig
schönes set und zwar gibt es die große
elli die minnelli und die single i
und wenn ihr gerne diese brotboxen
gewinnen wollt die wirklich in jede
küche reinpassen wo auch wirklich ganz
schön viel rein passt dann schreibt
einfach den hashtag west
[Musik]
also thema innovationen hier hinter mir
ist seht ihr den ersten wäscheständer
der sogar nachts leuchten und den
braucht aber etwas neues vielleicht auch
dass dem rat nachts immer gegen den
wäscheständer läuft ich glaube es ist
passiert aber vielleicht weiß einmal der
fall und wenn man dann so was zu hause
hat keine ahnung sind sachen die die
welt nicht braucht schaffen
[Musik]
touristischer genial gibt immer den
grill an den gibt es in verschiedenen
größen ein großes grill richtig super
war das war ziemlich schwer aber ich
glaube da vorne mich da jetzt drin
grille ich hier in dem ich glaube da
wird selbst ein monats das grill den
hubert geht eigentlich dass du kannst
dauereinsätzen
so hatte ich ja was für dich kunde
[Musik]
ja ich bin jetzt hier gerade bei lm w
und zwar eine firma aus ins sauerland
also ich glaub so langsam nicht mehr
dass die badener die innovativsten sind
sondern die aus dem sauerland muss ich
glaube ich echt zu geben weil die
letzten fünf firmen waren alle aus dem
sauerland tier bmws metallguss gibt es
einen fisch halter und zwar kann man
dann den fisch im ofen garen und
verstehens normalerweise um so in den
fisch hinlegen und das immer eine
hauptseite hat nicht so schön knusprig
und so haben wir den vorteil dass beide
seiten knusprig sind nicht echt aber wir
gucken hinten kurz den backofen bei ist
nämlich einer drin dass die der
verständigt
ich glaube den kürbis gleich essen wir
sind pünktlich zur essen gekommen
im türkischen unternehmer seine
schwiegermutter liebt sich also immer
dann kommt wenn das essen fertig wird
[Musik]
für mich gibt es hier noch den leckeren
fisch und für euch habe ich auch was und
war eine universal grillplatte mit fisch
haltern entweder für auf dem herd oder
für einen backofen damit einfach
kommentieren mit dem schrecken
[Musik]
ich glaube da findet man passende lampen
für unser zuhause
[Musik]
formationen aus schöne kehrten die
schwimmen dann auf der wasseroberfläche
[Musik]
der reporterin hund oder ich glaube wer
kriegt einfach den hier des pflegeleicht
schön bunt da willicks fressen den kanal
streicheln mit ins bett nehmen kasse
machen
[Musik]
die haben wir jetzt richtige unikate
sowie zum beispiel diesen vier meter
fünfzig langen tisch und zwar so wie
hier bei einer firma aus den
niederlanden also gar nicht so weit weg
von uns ein paar stunden mit dem auto
und hier findet man wirklich ganz ganz
tolle möbel wie den tisch oder auch hier
die wohnzimmertisch
hier sind sie unbehandelt hier auch
behandelt oder dahinten das regal dass
ich ja auch richtig genial und ich finde
wenn man bedenkt dass es weckt sie alles
naturholz ist sind die preise auch echt
völlig okay und bezahlbaren hatte echt
ganz ganz toll
[Musik]
als ich hier immer etwas richtig
geniales und zwar briefkästen und die
briefkästen die sehen nicht nur genial
aus sondern der aber auch im gadget das
heißt wenn man öffnet und das kommt
nicht rein
dann kommt der passende ton also noch
ach wie cool kommen ihm den froschkönig
marco s küste stehen mal gucken was
passiert
schreckt natürlich alle posten affen
schon klar
[Musik]
ob ich den mut zu einem apfel führen
kann
doch geht es ist eine kirsche aber ich
glaube damit geht noch das beste kommt
zum schluss jetzt wird ihm ist schon
verlassen wir haben gleich 18 uhr und
jeder geht in den feierabend und hier
wurde ich jetzt gerade noch angesprochen
und zwar wurde ich nach japan eingeladen
ich hatte mich nämlich gratis abstand
erkannt und nicht nur ich total
verwundert dass nämlich auch in japan
kennen und zwar bin ich hier bei den st
denn dann ist es ein verband und der
sitzt sozusagen die japanischer
handwerkskunst also die erfahren haben
wir wirklich eine ganz ganz tolle und
traditionelle handwerkskunst arbeiten
sehr präzise und sehr sauber und der
verband wählt dann die firmen aus oder
die fabriken die eben auch eine große
tradition haben und auch eine lange
tradition
voraussetzung ist dass es die firma
schon seit über 100 jahren gibt und seit
über 100 jahren auch die gleichen
materialien verwendet werden die
gleichen techniken und es sind einfach
gebrauchsgegenstände die man wirklich
jetzt im antrag auch gebrauchen kann wie
zum beispiel kosmetik pinsel oder auch
schöne zeller unterfordert ganz tolle
teller die zeige ich euch machen
ich habe zum beispiel dieser
wunderschönen teller jeder teller ist
ein unikat und hierbei werden
kirschbaum blätter draufgelegt und
eingedrückt da hat man so ein bisschen
die struktur dann kommt da eine farbe
drüber und wittern wieder weggewischt so
dass die farbe wirklich nur in diesem
kleinen rollen zu sehen ist und dass
wirklich jedes jahr jeder teller
jedes einzelne stück ein unikat wirklich
sehr schön und ich meine warum nicht
einfach mal nach japan reisen oder wir
sind offen für alles nämlich dem morath
mit und euch und dann können wir euch
ein bisschen zeigen
[Musik]
juni
dieses 2018 sechs tage auch ausgewählt
und die achtzehnte generation führt die
tradition weiter
ach wie schön und die blumen hatte
selber jetzt schön also das wurde er hat
den trend preis hier bekommen ok also
ich hier seht ihr mal die basis in basel
hat den trend preist ihr auf der
ambiente bekommen und erarbeitet der
firma schon in der 18
generation also wirklich
traditionsreiche familienunternehmen und
hier auf der messe hat er auch noch
vorgeführt wenn man diese blumen
herstellt also wenig wunder wunderschöne
handwerkskunst und das hat seine mutter
und seine frau bemalt danke und die
löffel hat und jetzt für zu hause
mitgegeben wirklich sehr schön er sagt
auch dass man davon essen sollte und
nicht von meta level mitarbeiter
geschmack viel anders ist und es wurde
zweimal von seiner mama und von seiner
frau
danke schön danke danke
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier noch kleine
geschenke für zuhause bekommen die ich
auch sehr zu schätzen weiß alles
handwerkskunst und mein tag auf der
ambiente hier ist es auch leider schon
vorbei
ich habe wirklich ganz viel gesehen aber
mannschaft wirklich nicht an einem tag
die komplette vielfalt ambiente zu sehen
und alle stände zu besuchen
man wird wirklich erschlagen von
neuheiten von der vielfalt hier auf der
messe
ich hoffe ich konnte euch einen kleinen
einblick geben ein paar neuheiten habe
ich wirklich entdeckt ich habe auch ganz
viele tolle familienbetriebe entdeckt
mit denen ich wahrscheinlich sehr gut
zusammenarbeiten kann und auch eigene
produkte entwickeln kann
und ihr dürft gerne wie gesagt schreiben
in die kommentare
welche geschenktüte bzw wenn ich das
geschenkpaket ihr gerne haben möchtet
werden wirklich ganz ganz tolle preise
für euch und kommentiert einfach nicht
los das ganze dann aus und dann bekommt
ihr die wahre zugeschickt also ich hoffe
euch hat das wieder gefallen wenn ja
dann lasst mir gerne im kommentar da und
wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal
bis dann
[Musik]
und der andere das kannst du nicht
einfach fotos zu machen
wir machen
[Musik]